une longue file d'attente pour assister
à ce que plusieurs surnommaient le
procès du siècle aux États-Unis
la foule s'était précipitée à la courte
tôt ce matin pour être au premier loge
le jury de 12 personnes venaient à peine
d'être sélectionné pour naître que
renvoyé en fin d'après-midi le procédant
rêvé sur la désinformation n'aura
finalement pas lieu les deux parties
s'entendent à l'amiable ce days
c'est autant de 787 millions de dollars
américains représentent l'imputabilité
et la responsabilité dit-il il y a des
conséquences et des mensonges
c'est un aveu de défaite dit l'équipe de
Dominion l'entreprise qui fabrique des
machines de vote électronique accusées
la chaîne Fox News d'avoir relayé des
mensonges au public en toute
connaissance de cause
les élections par des millions de votes
disaient une de ses avocats sur la
chaîne Fox News au lendemain de la
victoire de Joe Biden on pointe du doigt
le système de vote électronique de
l'entreprise de mignonne
c'est une élection volée répétée
de truquer les votes et dit-elle
l'animateur veut dette Toky Carson de
continuer à semer le doute
le vote électronique n'a pas permis aux
gens de voter dit-il sa fragilise notre
confiance au système c'est une menace à
la démocratie pourtant en privé dans les
échanges de textes et courriels les
animateurs vedettes rejettent les
allégations de Donald Trump mais en
ondes ils remettent en question le
système de votation pour ne pas perdre
les codes d'écoute ceci avec l'aval de
la direction la directrice de Fox new
susen Scott critique même un animateur
qui a osé vérifier des
ça doit s'arrêter cette vérification des
faits sur Trump et critel sur un
courriel c'est mauvais pour les affaires
nos téléspectateurs sont furieux ce
n'est pas bon pour nos affaires
aujourd'hui l'entreprise Dominion parle
d'une victoire pour la démocratie
dit le PDG de Dominion
honnête et factuel est essentiel pour la
démocratie ajoutée
représente un aval retentissant de la
vérité et de la démocratie dit-il de son
côté Fox News écrit dans un communiqué
nous reconnaissons que certaines
allégations concernant Dominion était
fausse cette entente reflète notre
engagement continuel pour un journalisme
de qualité